about other ways [ __ ] you are wait do I
have all my things what do you want so
this is the Killa now talking to us over
the radio each one is more twisted than
the last
right
and Marilyn I'm looking for something
[Music]
hey Becca hey P Piero Piero the pomace
super [ __ ] did he break it this is
nothing personal here's what I want you
to go to the tree oh yes [ __ ] bastard
well what the hell is this Wow
oh the night vision is picking picking
things up
white-painted of like
[Music]
but
[Music]
Patrick
all right how do I put your way take
[Music]
the sound seems richer than the last
true basis for a strong
that's where I haven't changed anything
maybe this
that difference
[Music]
is the different
let me know yeah everyone cuz you're not
complete ass outlast - I did didn't I
I think I did but I think I completed it
on our livestream pretty sure I complete
that game
okay so we need to go back to that tree
once wait
oh come here perhaps this is kind of AA
dog
yeah a good dog
[Music]
oh oh sorry my computer's about to run
out battery
there we go
oh yeah so I can't remember the way back
to the back to that tree but when you
show me
no as ahead in the Bronx
so in that case that may be the night
vision of this will help me
which way to go ah here we go hey
Paulette
but it with me please
heel
[Music]
picking me off
[Music]
good boys
well
[Music]
you did a Seiko I missed it what are you
talking about
wake you up the thing the thing
stay with me boy I like that before you
will I am using it I'm just trouble in
my little boy yeah he's a colors quick
fluorescent so that's gonna help us Oh
broke something
[Music]
does that break something why are you
I'm not just looking at the floor oh I
think I broke the game
shite no I don't want to do it again
shite how did I manage this yeah my boss
it's kind of crazy
oh I'm sucking away dimensions
I broke the game by petting the dog
maybe if I pet them again it'll slide
yeah can fixed it cuddling the dog
brutally middle
okay what's you miss fog Jeremy come
here boy
tell it we have Brian you have to kill
the dog I know you're there
careful now Ellis your little flashlight
won't help you here don't worry there
and I need your help
[Music]
the side
where's my dog
staples Boyd
weird doing here
[Music]
apparently
they completely
you
I'm going
the login the way yeah
go under yeah
[Music]
who's gonna keep booking strata
[Music]
easy boy no need to be scared oh you
sure are you sure about that
[Music]
[Music]
stay close bullet
we good
here we talkin some serious poet this
games functionality so the dog is lychee
like my saving grace
I know I know I know I know I know
[Music]
[Music]
you sure let me go left
[Music]
present happen there's a book here
No maybe I did no [ __ ] I've lost a thing
personified
[Music]
apparently guys what do I do
[Music]
everyone you remind me of Melissa I
don't know who really serese but I'll
she's nice okay we're making it
I think we hang close what I thought oh
I thought someone was knocking us
oh yeah where's my boy Ripper
where's my boy hey you
[Music]
[Music]
see things
what is this
which way do I go I like down there very
close sure
gotta get that somehow I think we're
down the bottom unlike around the side
of it this week give me this week how do
I get this week's tweet tweet to tweak
that tweets
okay believe I'm doing this
yeah what uses some hefty Thwaites
[Music]
wha-hey psycho
what the hell is this this thing bleeds
just halt I definitely I did it on
livestream I think so yeah and hopefully
we don't break the game by para good boy
hey Jack
[Music]
time to go to Dimension X with Dimension
X
hey Bastian
stay close bullet I'm just reiterating I
like these pots that I just have to use
the camera does it means I don't know a
junkie I mean did I miss
[Music]
this week
[Music]
oh my god I see people running in the
distance
[Music]
okay okay okay get in it oh yeah where's
my boy where's my good boy
oh [ __ ]
hey who's saying Tana sorry if I just
totally wrecked your name
[Music]
[Music]
that may eat up
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
I mean you're alive
five
over that
[Music]
the ground
Carmine's of her death stranding was
there
[Music]
[Music]
I had a broom apparently that konami
commissioned like some game studios to
do more stuff for sought help
the rumor is that there might be
announcing it this year but you know I
can't find this body path again Tripoli
he caught the odd one thanks peace
daddy-o tree
let me wait I think I've reached the end
of the map no I haven't I have actually
just lost
hopefully we'll find again
I know it's around here somewhere
Hey
Oh
you reckon I could just go
Oh close to them I can get I really
evolved it fast
maybe just go back
work out my flashlight
can i boy
okay now
[Music]
I keep thinking I find it
shite fat she lost it
I'm gonna get back
oh [ __ ]
some Aneesa
yeah I agree Michael they should not
inhale
I like they probably noticed their
mistake after that it was canceled it
was like oh crap we made the wrong
decision here but hey it worked out for
because you made it
yep
I guess
where's pop
where did we leave it
oh yes you're right I absolutely am one
morning doesn't know
hey call me [ __ ] out I was hopelessly
lost
I was a boy
I thought it's gonna put me back on this
[ __ ] path
why should I
I mean maybe [ __ ] that music I was
going the right way
Oh
apparently
stay close Boyd
[Music]
[Music]
anything
hopeless
[Music]
Ellen
my challenge
Wow
Ashley
I want to talk you're just gonna ignore
me now
No
[Music]
I'm just gonna keep going this way
[Music]
heroin felon
[Music]
[Music]
which way do you guys have a majority
because I I'm completely lost
got it boys jealous
[Music]
it's over that one over here
like oh ma
that way it's one that
one that
that one's pretty close
Carolyn going
[Music]
you know what that other ones gone
he's gone that I'm happy
wait that's the past
[Music]
it's gone that way okay
we found it halle-bloody-lujah
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you
okay
Oh
[ __ ] away
[Music]
don't lose the path though it's down
here somewhere
no I don't
so
really
[Music]
it's over that way though one morning
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
go around this way
[ __ ] there's one that [ __ ] oh why is
this so difficult if I can go around
both of them and they get around the
other side
[Music]
[ __ ] actually infuriating
the bloody path again
carry on
[Music]
carefully
[Music]
here
okay
we straight
Oh
this way
I hope this ends soon I'm done with it
now
traveling
I don't know what I know is I'm just
going on
[Music]
no one
okay
stay close boys
[Music]
keep your eye on the prize exact
laundering no more Monster your terror
man I I don't know
yeah I think the monsters are all around
us I don't think it was ever one monster
he gets the people that I don't know got
recruited by the witch or something and
now there's something else entirely
where did this
the tracks in here oh wow that's just
bollocks isn't it
he'll do you mean the tracks end here
where the [ __ ] am I supposed to go
[Music]
oh boy
okay saving it's saving this is good oh
but we just go into Bronx probably for
savings oh I understand it's dead
probably because I killed it some of the
boy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
of your way
dog scared of it don't like it you see
me scared at this how you always
Sentinel get is my own
[Music]
bullets buddy wait
you're not afraid of it no question
asking
[Music]
I realize you know in my viewfinder
[Music]
right behind you boy
[Music]
right now
Hey
go on boy check it out stay safe
[Music]
yeah
we have to do something
I have snacks what's not
[Music]
good boy
well that make you feel better no no oh
yes it does
[Music]
[Music]
keep talking before this is over I'll
make you pay for what you did what again
[Music]
crowd hand up
is he just playing with us only solution
was to just give up
[Music]
hmm do you actually put aside if we
hadn't done when you told us to the
curious about me wants to just really do
this whole thing necessary but I'm not
[Music]
son oh yeah good dog
[Music]
[Music]
I don't like to look at this buddy
no one bit
so what is it another body
[Music]
I don't understand you want me
kill myself
you know what oh [ __ ] you no no no I
will not kill bullet I should have drawn
one long ago I'm not doing this anymore
stop hiding behind a child you coward
god damn it good
I wasn't saying if the game makes me
kill the daughter I don't thinking I'm
gonna play it anymore no that's that's
impossible
bullet No
[Music]
but again bullet bullet Hey
oh look where are you bullets
hey bullets wait up bullet where are you
hey bullet wait up hold on boy I am
coming
[Music]
oh god no please don't move buddy don't
move don't move
you should sisters it's gonna be fine
let me just die
[Music]
oh you're heavy
someone's been eating too much scraps
from the table
got to take longer walks buddy all
around the block I'm not kidding
okay it's just it's gonna be okay
[Music]
hey Alex oh no I think I don't might be
dying because the murderer wanted I did
see your question but I just I can't
answer properly now just wait until the
end of the stream and then ask me again
[Music]
it'll be alright buddy
there's a weird market are they walking
for the spatula
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I like some
bullet bowel down some rock things badly
injured but the guy the murderer wanted
us to kill a little it's you just before
and we wouldn't do it just seems a bit
coincidental
lie that says library
not this again
I don't think these are words I can't
make it out there was something on the
rocks I can't make out if it's prayers
on
don't well we're just gonna run in
circles
[Music]
we've always this heavy
[Music]
oh I think they're turning into words as
we go around so there's left single dogs
I think it says let the dog die oh no I
think he says let the dog die
if to look at it as a Mangalore that
makes sense
laughs I think it's I think it's is mrs.
Holt asking every clue
let's
[Music]
doing girls night
drugs
[Music]
dogs dogs
[Music]
oh geez I hope not
I think we huh I think the game is
making us alex easier I'm here with you
that's dying dogs lie that dying dogs
lie
[Music]
is even telling us on the screen now
that dying does lie No
[Music]
I was leading anyone we came here
together while walking down together
[Music]
P City I would just keep walking forever
[Music]
[Music]
we're having another PGA moment
either that or we're really struggling
to hold up as big girl we'd maybe a bit
of both
[Music]
already don't want to end this game
he said and they did this on bloody
purpose they knew how much you'd end up
relying on the dogs forming a
relationship with the dog
it's the only sense of safety you have
in the game
[Music]
and now they're gonna forcibly take it
away from you
right before the climatic ending
[Music]
I heard there were multiple endings
though so maybe there was away although
either way still
we just turn around
[Music]
nope I refuse I ain't joking around I'm
not going the same way
[Music]
getting brands I can't even
what am i yeah what if I keep moving
backwards and then I just suddenly get
better
I'm definitely getting
oh the boys with my head up back
[Music]
the rich
[Music]
yes
[Music]
bliss No
now [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah first scene out for the dog nothing
happens
that's how I would call him to us
nope 10 around you won't break me you
hear me
Tyrell I won't lose to you
a winter it'll snap and kill his wife
[Music]
maybe I should have sent around this
look amazed here
and a dog if there was a way I will find
it
this again
oh no I don't think I should just call
either
Oh
[Music]
don't do it we don't know what he'll do
Oh what the guy coverage
[Music]
Charis god dammit Ellis I've been trying
to reach you for hours anyway I just
wanted to say they were close he died
nothing personal but hey you left him
there to die it's only fair you die
alone out there as well
ready ready oh my god
i lunch everyone
[Music]
oh I'm still playing
[Music]
[Music]
but it doesn't like him I got
achievement
[Music]
[Music]
like a llama just I keep getting
messages Oh God
are you guys ready
[Music]
no like I can't take it anymore make it
stop works dammit
see anything nah
it's gonna keep pressing forward and
just hope that I'm going
[Music]
what what
[Music]
[Music]
light
[Music]
think I just went to sit
[Music]
love the ulama go in
[Music]
okay so I'm killing one of her little
monsters but why does the witch want me
to do that
what that's all thing when I can little
minions
why would you want many fewer minions
[Music]
wait should we ready be doing what she
tells us maybe we shouldn't do what she
tells us to do by hey Kelly
um
[Music]
she'll be like not
[Music]
Oh
we should just say hi to them
Hey
underneath yet
look what I did allow us to do
let's look you hey Kaley
what happened to his dog you think he
didn't do it
[Music]
I don't know what over here is to me
Alice
[Music]
it's me
[Music]
what if I dug you didn't do anything I
don't think you did anything you didn't
do anything
you loved him
[Music]
Jess I was it yes
we're like dipping in between reality
[Music]
which
[Music]
and I just I just Kelly already
beautiful
what does you're still struggling huh do
it again that's what you're worried
about stupid little man a gonna slit
your throat and wear your skin you'll
have to work for that no you did this
all I did was give you a choice you
chose the dog and now it's dead a filter
I feel she
now you have nothing
[Music]
I'm so sorry for everything if only I
could only just please I know I messed
up you killed them Ellis what you're a
murderer and a coward
I'm leaving Gillis you know what you
need to do be a man for once
[Music]
[Music]
why I did everything you wanted me to
what the hell am I supposed to do now
who are they okay
I don't want without fallin
[Music]
[Music]
to be something useful
the blue tapes I can't
[Music]
God get up
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
wait
oh my god
I know spies twice by the house
[Music]
no going back Ellis
it never was let's get this over oh no
it's in days
so I have to choose which door
choose you
[Music]
nope don't have that much player agency
let's go
but then this sudden my sister wasn't
spiced wait what
what's that
oh my gosh I've seen this in maybe a
couple of horror movies now it's a good
little tactic a good little scare tactic
it's got to be a key somewhere I mean
the gain wants me to go says but I'm
gonna have a little ground first
last lesson with patient he is leaving
Burkittsville in his own words he feels
he's able to move on I'm glad about this
that's thought about the how he'll be
enlisting in the military service joy
while of what effect this environment
will have on a sensitive psyche the
stress and trauma of active duty might
completely displaces charge of trauma
with it words the same trauma that he
already seems to forgotten however I'm
afraid the words will never leave it no
matter what occurs it will remain
beneath the formative experience that
made him furious today
come back to the woods
pots
yogurt pots and tins Lisa's been feeding
a boy hopefully
like a suit this one
oh yeah this is where I came in okay
sorry don't mind me just being stupid
miss Paula
[Music]
he is
there is whoever gave us the ball was
trying to help us
my house
you ready guys
please Eddie I love how the cameras and
when I about you they're looking out
last I agree especially this second game
it was just by the end it was so stress
inducing Carlos is running one time
how's it back here Petey vibes
more budge that one was different the
light just made it Angry
haha
how do I turn off the light
[Music]
just continue without any lights
but can't do that Jhansi
I'm King very confused
come out just right
broken
work stocked up
Oh can open a door
don't think I can peek around corner so
I'm just doing it my own way
[ __ ]
now
see even though this is like Oh
a battery
cool cuts it up
oh boy
[Music]
turn off the water that's such a waste
kidding me
shortly
huh
two things
yeah
so that door won't help you
yeah I don't think I can turn off the
light because they're both connected see
the like the flashlight was up the top
right and now it's it's aimed at the
camera and I don't know how to turn it
off I'm doing like left click and stuff
it's not
do-right Peter
this doesn't seem real this seems very
nice that I want to get in there
uh-huh
that's normal
[Music]
this is boy even real and I've chasing
something that's nice - my dog died for
nothing
[Music]
called me in it
[Music]
start for you hours
it gives you power gives you a chance to
hold life in your palm you touch the
twigs and you run your fingers through
their bones you press them down you
break their spine she watches you once
you pick them up she won't let you put
them down and her whispers become
sweeter every time you clench your fists
so I shouldn't have been doing that I
shouldn't have been breaking them I
thought I was like hindering her not
helping her
[Music]
my bad
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to support animations
so cool
maybe this Ashley
it's gonna go forwards of course of
course now we have to go back the way we
came all right can I move
not again
what's done is done no point dwelling on
the past
this is your chance to do something good
Ellis don't waste it
[Music]
to come to you
[Music]
and we're back upstairs right
wait
someone's wallet
jazz it's just too much I can't take any
more
I've won that you track me down baby no
I don't believe that's don't believe it
don't believe it Oh
[Music]
[Music]
so how many years this event or
[Music]
oh no I shouldn't be doing this
come it I tried to right-click instead
of that way
[Music]
oh here in a charming mood today anyone
hear me turn on the lights the
headlights turn them on wait huh that's
me
that was someone said she was earlier in
the game but now it's us
[Music]
the cards
[Music]
yeah that's photography founder the
hoarding is anyway
[Music]
No
[Music]
little sketchy and the D fighter tariff
Oh
so this guy died in the beginning of the
game skies I told you we were the killer
didn't I say that
[Music]
I mean I shouldn't be happy about this
but I did call it noise how do you
imagine it your pleasure are you a good
man Alice
don't touch
there's no other way that does neat past
ethic some help
Oh how do I turn off the bloody knife
please my friend like
[Music]
oh how to switch out the light
this is huggable
hugging the wall wall is turning hugging
the wall
hugging the wall
honking the wool I think I've read I
have to walk
be a man for once oh that's what it says
on the wall this way
like the weight said don't look like the
weight sir but I don't know how to keep
don't know how to keep the camera up and
not have the light on it actually
wait I'm just gonna see if I'm just
gonna see in settings if that is a way
No
just put the whole thing down
down
hug the wall hug the roll
hug the wall
hug the wall just hug it
I think for I did it
[Music]
the attacks when I forget it
[Music]
couldn't go that way
Oh God okay where's the Sun in this game
it's a hurricane there is no Sun
Oh rude
[Music]
Conrad Conrad Conrad
maybe fire
watch the tape this happened
[Music]
it might be somewhere else maybe not
down here
this is come from man
I came from we got a robbery in progress
a convenience store near Burkittsville
Road those kids again yeah
[Music]
cool
you know what's not helping the
situation
effect I need to pee
Alice what are you doing out here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is very cool
dear okay do you copy
[Music]
become very brave should we say hi
[Music]
I think it's just a cuddly toy
I do want that please
can't bloody see
[Music]
so disorienting
[Applause]
she wasn't this the his psychiatric room
stay on him
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
a local teenager allegedly involved in a
convenience store library was shot by a
police officer arriving at the scene the
suspect was transported to a nearby
hospital in critical condition
local authorities confirmed that the
suspect was unarmed
wait so he was in the military and that
a bunch of people died or he feels he
did he was also police over 70 killed
someone who is unarmed
fools
what
- a blame for that it's not where it all
started is it me like an intentional
I've seen this room before
yeah quite a few times now
this statue
huh
this is very life life
good craftsmanship
here comes our handsome lad hey the dude
he's gotten a pretty penny Papa they'd
betray me you know what kind of girl
would 1h he's coming
[Music]
sir I'm lost please help me Oh
yes that's what we see someone from this
path
the soldiers sir sir yes sir
free butcher
sir
sir sure
sir sir sir
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
ya see let's mad
- dad of the keep the only one who
survived
one entering the urban area
[Music]
[Music]
forced
[Music]
ya see all the people who were picked up
that all the people from
[Music]
some are mounted
who is it
- I just sneak that oh this is the
so this is the room where we select I
get like chopped up
like kava
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
it's weird I can only seem to turn on
some Oh
here we go it's the broom
seems familiar somehow
[Applause]
he is here shuddered
like God the planks had one hell of a
shoulder that's okay we're pausing here
I'm gonna leave you hanging just for a
second because I need to go to the
toilet and this could be bad if I get
jumpscared while I need to go for a pee
so I'll be right back
see you momentarily
I am back
Wow was annoying pool sound well I guess
it's like camera noise isn't it uh
anyway my shadow it's
Oh
here we go again
just hug the wool and everything
[Music]
looking at you look you dad you look
okay
okay maybe I can keep going it attacks
when I look at it
so where is it again you can look today
no it's outside
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
I was gonna say up cool down guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
I think I made it there and then I
turned around and went back same way
again walking
oh [ __ ] looking
[Music]
laughs another lap Allan Poe
Keith forced without the wolf strategy
thing
Sylvester boys
Roscoe had a word
they're all dead because of me
this
[Music]
goddammit
ready
[Music]
your summers
cool
[Music]
[Music]
who's that
so someone when they turned around
finally all the other pictures bring
their backs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they wanna see them I didn't see that
[Music]
[Music]
sit No
stuff get a hold of yourself
he killed a civilian I raise whoa no I
mean like that's bad enough
[Music]
[Music]
I don't like to carry something
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm wondering the same thing
[Music]
I've been waiting for you
Oh
I better learn its motion
[Music]
[Music]
they don't know which way I've got to go
though
[Music]
okay
okay
okay
[Music]
yeah I've been melis right ravely
actually
[Music]
[ __ ] this this is nope nope nope I was
like let's run maybe not
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
I just turn back around again
you're nothing
[Music]
[Music]
you can't look at yourself in the mirror
anymore can you
no is too ugly why did I pick up a
battery
[Applause]
get in the corner don't look at her
[Applause]
nice knees how I died
[Music]
what did I do
and then I'll be safe there
[Music]
nope
she's turning me guys she's turning me
come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's her thing as the witch
your tolling still again
[Music]
what's happened trip you all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
basically everyone that we killed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's making
[Music]
this is a super cool camera effects and
I really want to talk the Welman app but
I only did this that man lived here
maybe 40 years
oh that's hard that's a woman
[Music]
[Music]
take your head
[Music]
wait a second
Donovan
[Music]
I
[Music]
what the hell just happened
what was that I think you're turning
into a monster
this is it the basement finally Jesus
completely here it took so long Peter
Peter Peter where are you you showering
[Music]
I think you killed them all
[Music]
look he's not here
you really think you would be that easy
Yellin the kid won't be waiting here for
you you leave him and go home my hero
you don't get dad where are you mother
[ __ ]
show yourself I'm gonna kill you with my
bare hands and after what you've done
I'm going to enjoy it
come on then the key is under the table
now waiting on the other side
Oh
thanks Diana
I like
drops down
he's going men old says you're your
terror man
[Music]
[Music]
seriously
[Music]
I can learn from this game
[Music]
love these transition shots
[Music]
no no no no please please please please
come on I'm not gonna hurt you
please please please please please
he did
sorry
[Music]
this is what you think your [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] it's finally all those
people children I'll rip your [ __ ]
heart
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh wait I mean
Alice gave into his rage despair the
cycle continues karma was born again
yeah wait no no not good I mean bullet
but it survives he was like if I'm
wandering outside the Shannon's house
yeah I really thought dog survived so
have brother just cut all no ties that
is after learning of his fate she didn't
say a word
wait so she found help but he became
Carver Peters favorite means unknown
ah see how happen to the point
what with no clue to its whereabouts
Sheriff's man's body was never to
rediscovered blackness for us
Thom McCann's body was found months
later the Tamizh creeks or mouse so
rotten it
they've got the bad ending guys
[Music]
anything else
anything else anything else no there you
go
now I'm gonna spend the rest of my
evening watching all the other endings
I'm wondering what did I do wrong
but at least the dog survived I'm sure
that was probably an ending where bullet
did not survive so I'm proud of these
that we managed to keep her alive
yeah exactly Michael that's what I want
to know as well I wanna know is there a
way to not give in to rage I want to
know this I want to know but anyway
thank you so much for watching me play
Blair Witch I will be releasing all of
these live streams public to YouTube I
want to do the last one as well as this
one
I just like to cut them down a little
bit first just the beginning in endings
so that other than it's more do you
watch a boy you don't have to skip to
try and find where it actually starts
but yeah thank you so much for watching
I was very happily surprised with that
game i-i've watched Blair Witch I think
it's it was a great horror film for its
time it was um you know the first kind
of handheld footage movie which was a
very new and unique but now it's kind of
mean over Dawn's tie boring and I didn't
have like amazing expectations for this
game specially after playing outlast but
I am so just overwhelmed with what they
managed to do with it and how they
bought it from just being a horror game
about kind of witches and a haunted ask
would to real life situations and mental
health and you know brought it upon this
man and the things that he has done and
damn he did some bad things at first I
just thought oh you know you kill people
by accident in the war but he didn't
mean to
and I blames himself but now it turns
out he was also a policeman and he shot
someone unarmed and he killed a civilian
and that's why I kept seeing his eyes
pop up it was very good I felt very
confused and lost for a lot of the game
but I feel like that was by design
because obviously the character that
you're playing feels confused not and he
doesn't know what's what's real and not
a lot of the time and he's obviously
battling with internal struggles of
whether he is good or bad and what he
did
was truly how he remembers it being or
not
so they conveyed that very wealthy at
the gameplay and damn that ending that
ending those camera effects and
transitions and everything I want to
talk to that cinematics team
I want to learn from that game I was
always very impressed very impressed way
you made this game I'm just gonna Google
it's a Blair Witch the Lubar team the
blue bird blue bird why the games have
they done we slow down a little rabbit
hole
Bluebird oh yeah of course they did
layers of fear as well that game was
pretty too so they they know how to make
pretty games oh and they made that
observer game I heard about that one
look pretty interesting dude dude I'm
very impressed I am very impressed I'm
gonna look more into this it's actually
inspired me more for my unreal horror
videos that I've been attempting to
create all of my little lonesome just
made me their camera effects and the
things that they use the kids like how
they use the camera is very inspiring
very well done
anyway so I know that you have a voice
shot on your disco do you think we can
chat on one of your lines to see the
voice Channel maybe Alex but I'm not too
sure because you know I'm just like into
the game when I'm live-streaming but
we'll see what the future holds usually
when I'm on discord though I'm like I'm
just kind of in dipping in and out in a
month doing work and things like that so
I can't really be on be on the voice
chat but you guys can use it to like
chat together and stuff and don't forget
just because I have finished Blair which
does not mean that live streams are
stopping I'm gonna try and do one every
Wednesday evening probably about 5:30
ish p.m. so join me again next week
but just to make sure you don't miss out
I will update you all on Twitter and the
discord as well so I have put a little
link to my Twitter I just get a little
oh I got a little share for the UM
discord as well
[Music]
dude stop
okay you look in the if you look in the
description there will be a link to join
the discord but yeah I'm gonna go now
cuz I've got dinner to make and more
work to do sometimes so yeah thank you
so much for joining me I keep on seeing
so yeah so it's probably very like
goodbye you to wrap around Deuter you
root our man I always toggle this to say
your name goodbye Michael tonic goodbye
axe the observer goodbye Michael tannic
did I just say that goodbye peace daddy
goodbye dr. jonathan MX mood damage own
at the end of stream no don't worry i
will put this all up so you can see the
whole of it or you can join me next week
bye rosin by maria pizza the game has
insane graphics s so good yeah it was it
was a very pretty game definitely good
bye lovie skip the credits and then
google day yesterday
goodbye anyone Rafa SoDo goodbye Jamie
and goodbye anyone who is watching but
it's not in the chat I still appreciate
you being here and I hope to see you
again next week for more fun video games
oh also yeah make sure that you are
following on Twitter actually cuz I'll
probably put a poll up on what my next
game should be but I'm thinking I need
to look at my budget but I'm thinking I
might play
alta Wilde's not other worlds Alto wilds
I've heard so much about that game I've
heard so much about the narrative design
of a design of that game and I'm very
intrigued to play it and see what it's
all about so let me know your thoughts
on that anyway
have a lovely day or evening